on poursuit cette page loisir avec vos
idées de sortie Gabriel alors pour les
ce vendredi c'est les vacances de la
tousin et du coup vous n avez prévu
décider de sortir un peu spécial pour
l'occasion oui et pour bien commencer
les vacances je vous propose une
exposition au château de Breteuil les
Playmobil réinvestissent les lieux pour
une exposition sur le thème de
l'histoire vous voyagerez avec le
célèbre jouet allemand Playmobil des
dinosaures à la conquête spatiale les
figurines exposées de façon éphémère
sont issues de la collection privée du
collectionnaire Dominique betthune pour
y assister rendez-vous au château de
Breteuil les 21 et 22 octobre Mathilde
et qui dit vacances de la toussin dit
Halloween et la fête s'invite à la
Bergerie Nationale de Rambouillet oui
cette année vous partirez à la rencontre
de quatre maisons de sorcier pour
découvrir des activités Agri enchantées
au programme labyrinthe de l'oreur
découverte du jardin des citrouilles et
déambulation dans la ferme vous y
trouverez bien sûr les incontournables
de la Bergerie nationale comme la traite
des des vaches et le soin aux animaux le
1er novembre une nocturne est organisée
avec un clu et grandeur nature
rendez-vous donc sur le site internet de
La Bergerie Nationale pour réserver vos
billets direction maintenant le château
de Versailles où une programmation
spéciale est proposée aux familles
pendant les vacances oui et plusieurs
visites insolites sont proposées parmi
elles un parcours théâtralisé avec des
comédiens une chasse au trésors et une
plongée dans les archives du château les
enfants et les familles sont également
invités à suivre les traces des jeux et
des divertissements de la Cour dans une
visite intitulée Versailles des jeux du
sport enfin autre visite à noter les
familles vont pouvoir partir à la
découverte des sculptures d'animaux du
château pour ensuite modeler les leurs
accompagné par une sculptrice
professionnelle vous nous parlez à
présent d'un festival qui mêle l'art et
la science oui il s'appelle le festival
curiositas et il revient pour une 7e
édition alors l'événement met à
l'honneur notre univers au sens large
une façon de montrer au travers des
œuvres que ceux qui qui nous entoure
émerveille aussi bien les scientifiques
que les artistes l'occasion aussi de
rapprocher ces deux domaines longtemps
opposés pour créer une réflexion commune
au programme exposition spectacle
projection et rencontres le festival se
tient dans plusieurs lieux dans les
ivelines rendez-vous dans les campus de
Versailles et de Guy encours de l'UVSQ
mais aussi dans les médiathèques du
canal et Anatole France et on termine
avec un aniversaire et un rendez-vous
culinaire à ne pas manquer oui pour les
10 ans du centre commercial one nation
au cl sous-bois le Centre organise un
show culinaire une cuisine éphémère sera
dressée pour l'occasion de grands noms
de la gastronomie française seront
présents les 21 et 28 octobre le chef
étoilé Jean-François Piège proposera
deux recettes sur le thème zéro
gaspillage le chef Roan herbeless de son
côté rendra hommage à ses origines avec
des recettes colombiennes ça donne envie
hein oui ça donne envie merci beaucoup
Gabriel Gontier pour toutes ces idées de
sortie